we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we had a
caller last week during live calls
asking about the rise of the nationalist
right in poland and here is a voicemail
about what happened when we did that
story take a listen to this oh my gosh
these alright
[ __ ] are already pouring in to your
video about poland's far-right it's
absolutely disgusting these people are
already this video there's only been up
for like thirty minutes that i was like
three hundred fifty views and there's
already the swarms of all right asses in
the comments i hope your moderators are
up for the task yeah buy it it's just
par for the course
yeah i mean any time we talk about there
are certain hot-button issues where when
the YouTube clip publishes it just gets
totally brigaded by some combination of
all rightists white nationalists
national nationalist extremists
it's a nightmare and it's par for the
course we're gonna keep talking about
these issues we've been talking about it
in the united states we've been talking
about it in europe and it's just what we
have to do and you know we the sad
reality of it is that we get so many
comments on youtube that we just can't
police every comment if i or any of the
other moderators see comments that are
spam right like links to people's
affiliate programs that have nothing to
do with our content or obviously
offensive or hateful content we'll just
delete it but by and large there's very
little moderation because we're getting
thousands of comments a day literally
thousands of comments a day on our
youtube channel we just can't keep up
with it all
so we'll do what we can and yeah i'm not
surprised at all to hear that on today's
bonus show select boston lift passengers
are already getting rides in
self-driving cars we will talk about a
very interesting analysis that shows
that Google Street View can predict the
racial and political orientation the
race and political orientation of
neighborhoods based on the vehicles in
the neighborhood
and did NASA find alien life that's what
the headline says we will talk about a
new finding by Kepler on today's bonus
show get access to the bonus show two
ways david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
you can get a free 20 18 david pakman
show calendar if you sign up for a
yearly membership at david pakman.com
slash calendar 18 please be aware that
you can't get the free calendar with a
monthly membership because we we could
end up losing money we're trying to
raise money for the show not lose money
and you can't get the free calendar if
you get a discounted membership okay for
it to make sense mathematically and
economically for us to get the free
calendar you've got to go to david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 use the
link there and it's a full price
membership okay and if you are an
existing member or patron you can keep
what you have if you want and get the
calendar at a discount we've announced
that discount code a number of times on
the bonus show and on patreon and in an
email blast to all of our members so
stick with what you have if you want and
just get the discounted calendar usually
the most economically sensible way to go
about it all right we'll talk to you on
today's bonus show